Catherine is with us in Tucson Arizona
hi Catherine how are you good how are
you better than I deserve what's up so
my husband and I found a house that we
love neighborhood we love and this is
going to be long-term for us like my
goal is to pay off my house and die
there so you want to live there forever
about at least but that's the goal we're
not looking into like flip it or move in
three years you know so we have two
credit cards that haven't been paid off
yet you're not ready to buy a house okay
the reason we were thinking about doing
it because we can even we do our
mortgage and extra on our credit cards
everyone's talking about how know
everyone everyone everyone's broke and
and everyone's got an opinion about
money I strongly recommend you do not
buy a house until your debt free and you
have your emergency fund plus your down
payment and it'll help if you don't go
house shopping for you're ready to buy a
house that way you don't get house fever
and do something dumb okay yeah I please
please please you're going to get
yourself in a mess how much credit card
debt have you got about fifteen thousand
yeah and your household incomes what
seventy five thousand yeah you got you
got a little work to do for y'all right
about now I have a question because
we're renting we were renting for three
years and our rent is $1,000 a month and
our mortgage would be fifteen hundred
yeah what so that's why it's like do we
is it five hundred
that's $500 more towards your getting
out of debt that's true that's true and
you got you guys got a mess on your
hands I mean you've been spending more
than you make for some time yes when we
were first married I made a lot of
stupid decisions but we've paid off a
lot both of our cars are paid off we've
been getting on the right track good how
much have you paid off so far let see we
paid off my car and how much money have
you paid off something I'm trying to
think I would say about fifteen to
twenty thousand and how long did that
take we've been married for seven years
no I mean you've been working on the
debt for seven years
no let's see so three because the past
three years hasn't got a good paint job
and we felt like and like okay well let
me help you with this making seventy
five thousand dollars a year you should
pay off fifteen thousand dollars in
credit card debt in about nine months
well he just got he hasn't always make
Antonio no I'm staying ready set go we
need to clean this up so you can buy a
house how come
yeah but you need to really get after it
I mean stay out of the restaurant less
you're working there okay you don't need
to go on vacation and we haven't you
need to cut Christmas back we we live
pretty low on the internet I want you to
really get in attack mode is what I'm
saying because that fifteen thousand
dollars in debt is standing between you
and buying a house wisely now I'm not
sure I've talked you out of this because
I think I I think I took your pulse and
I think you have house fever which is
usually when your brain quits working
and you buy a house whether you can
afford one or not because people say
they said I said fifteen hundred versus
a thousand all this kind of crap starts
going on so I hope I've woke you up you
may need to take a cold shower though
that helps with a guy with house fever
but you definitely got house fever be
careful because house features paper
cause you do dumb things like those
credit cards did a few years ago you're
going to get yourself in a mess you go
buying a house and you keep piling on
these debts and you don't have Murphy
will move in your spare bedroom when you
buy us with debt and no money broke
people buying a house is a curse it
curses you it doesn't bless you and you
want the house to be a blessing and not
a curse
Oh